there was no holding back u.s president
donald trump and his democratic
challenger joe biden
went on the attack in a chaotic first
televised debate
moderator chris wallace struggled at
times to control the discussion as the
candidates
repeatedly interjected and talked over
each other
the debate questions ranged from
coronavirus and the economy
race relations and violence in the u.s
but the answers often devolved into
angry exchanges
and personal insults did you use the
word smart
so you said you went to delaware state
but you forgot the name of your college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe
with you wait a minute you get the final
word well it's hard to get any word in
with this clown excuse me this
hey let me just say for more i'm joined
here in the studio by dw's stacy
bivens good to see you stacy hi terry oh
that wasn't really much of a debate i
mean we saw an almost civil
uh cut there from the debate uh it was
more like a shouting match most of the
time did we
learn anything uh it was just really
messy very distracting and it managed to
thread the needle between
being extremely boring at some points
and then just being really
stressful for the viewer and other
points but i think that was part of the
strategy for donald trump um because
he's had a tough week with his taxes
coming out
and with the coronavirus and the fallout
with the economy with the coronavirus
so i think that his strategy was to try
to keep joe biden off his
toes like keep him off center and to
distract him from
from the issues and confuse the rest of
us
of course the pandemic is foremost in
everyone's mind right now
getting that behind us joe biden was
trying to press
donald trump on his handling of the
pandemic but the
president definitely pushed back let's
take a listen
but i'll tell you joe you could never
have done the job that we did you don't
have it in your blood you could have
never done that you have
i know how to do the job i know how to
get the job well you didn't do very well
in swine flu
h1n1 you were a disaster your own
children
was a disaster 14 000 people died not
200 000 there was no
economic recession
you made a point and there was no one
there's no we didn't shut down the
economy
this is his economy that's being he shut
down
well trump there saying biden couldn't
have done what he did to protect
americans in this pandemic but stacy did
biden say he would have
what he would have done differently in
handling the coronavirus well he mainly
focused on the fact that there weren't
enough ppe's and that he would have made
sure that that would have happened
that there had been enough funding for
small businesses so that
so many wouldn't have gone under and
then there would have been enough
money to open up schools because it's
expensive to keep them in line with the
cdc guidelines
but one of the points that he did get in
was it says here it was
it is what it was because you are who
you were and that's talking about uh
donald trump when
we got to the 200 000 number and donald
trump threw his hands up and was like
well it is what it is
so joe joe biden was able to point out
that this was
trump's economy and this was his
handling of the coronavirus
that that has impacted so many americans
now debate also touched on i mean
touched on lots of issues but including
racial tensions and violence in the u.s
here's one exchange on that
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you doing what are you saying i'm i'm
willing to do anything i want to see
peace then do it sir
say it do it say it do you want to call
him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white supremacy
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
because this is not a right-wing problem
this is a lefty director
moving
obviously a very contentious issue there
um not just for the candidates for
in the united states as a whole
reflecting those tensions how did
the two candidates or the president and
his challenger
approach the issue of race in this
debate well i have to say that it's
disappointing that a sitting u.s
president
can't outright condemn white supremacy
and he refused yet again when he had the
opportunity to
do so and he also didn't focus on why
people were protesting
in the first place it's racial injustice
and
we have people of various economic
backgrounds ethnicities
men women different ages all marching
because they see
an injustice and you can't tell people
like my white brother-in-law
that who's a teacher who's marching for
the rights of his two black sons
that there's something wrong with him
that he's a member of antifa
donald trump also doubled down on this
idea
that he is the president
of red states the way he was talking
about
the democratic governors and how they
handle things he focuses mostly on
the red states and he fails to
understand or care that he's the
president of
of all the united states and that's an
issue trump's refusal to
condemn uh just distance himself from
white supremacists and condemn them
one of the main takeaways from this
debate i would say
politics is incredibly polarized in the
united states right now
do you think that undecided voter voters
watching this debate
will have been swayed either way by what
they heard i mean this was pretty bad
right this was a horrible debate one of
the worst i i've ever seen
um but i will say that if you were a
donald trump supporter before you were
still a donald trump supporter you felt
like
his tactics were good and that he he
showed how weak
joe biden was and if you're a joe biden
supporter you're still a joe biden
supporter and you feel like he was
thoughtful and that's what you want to
stand a president
the amount of people who are still
undecided is so small
and i think that those people probably
have an idea of who they would vote for
they just needed to have a little bit of
a push to force them to go outside of
their homes to the polls
and vote many are saying this is joe
biden's
election to lose he is ahead in the
polls right now and many were
hoping he wouldn't trip up too badly
last night which
many say he did not but anyway trump and
biden will face off two more times in
televised presidential debates before
the election which is just a little more
than a month away
can we expect much of the same you think
we'll see anything different let's hope
it's not the same this was really
horrible
but what i will say is that one of the
upcoming debates is a town hall
and that's where joe biden usually seems
to shine because he's able to connect
with people
and let's just see what happens because
donald trump is having so many problems
now in the press with his taxes and so
forth
so let's see if he brings forth a
different strategy this time around
stacy thank you so much for your
analysis dw's stacey bivens
thank you terry